what is the last question uh you were
named salon's sexiest man of the year
of 2013.
i don't know what does that mean i don't
i really don't know i thought it was
it's first of all
let's say it fueled by white guilt and
that's
that is a hundred percent true
so what
comedians are supposed to be you know
soft
and you're
oh oh god i just benched 450.
that would be like how much superman
benches
450 pounds
you don't have to answer it but just
think in your head how much do you weigh
i weigh about 2 30 so it would be
benching two of you
that's a lot of
you
you'd have to look like superman to do
that could you bench me
yeah you could i don't know how we i
don't know if i could put you on a spit
like a
like a like make you like into a
foosball person then i could do it
is gonna end poorly
i think you would have to time of my
life mate
oh